you had back in the day quite a
reputation for trashing hotel rooms and
it got to the point where I would
imagine it would be hard for you to have
been able to stay in a hotel when they
saw you coming you said hey Joe Walsh I
want to check in why would they let you
stay there well maybe a ten thousand
dollar security deposit you would
seriously leave a ten thousand dollar
security deposit
well I'm exaggerating but they needed
some kind of assurance yeah so you might
my job really when I checked out was to
get across the state line before the
maid saw the room what's the most damage
you ever did to a hotel room what's the
most accost you $23,000 well I have a
disclaimer okay John Belushi was a
really good friend of mine and when he
came over pretty much you just cancelled
all your plans for the next like 24
hours right and he came over to my hotel
room
and what happened we stayed up for a
couple weeks at night
[Applause]
and what did you do to the room well we
have a police officer getting the
details afterwards I'm trying to think
what cost that my guests or is this a
deposition yeah well we'll tell you
afterwards all right so what did you do
to a room that cost that much well we
had access to the penthouse suite mm-hmm
right yeah and we didn't know it was the
owner of the hotels private apartment
but there was really nice artwork so we
didn't want to mess with that but we
didn't like the wallpaper so we took the
paintings down and tore all the wall
people off and put the paintings back on
you can see where the plaster guy wrote
you know 5 and 3/4 inches right right
right
much better yeah you like it better you
should have given him a bill you made
his place better I did unfortunately it
didn't work that way yeah okay
you